you want to tell her
i i moved out we're separated that's
right 90 day fiance stars colt and
vanessa have split so you two are
separated now you're not living together
she's having to live with us for three
weeks during the 90 day the single life
tell-all special the married couple
reveal they are no longer living
together and why in a shocking twist
involving colt's mom debbie i'm upset
that you just can't do anything by
yourself i'm the first person to first
call the first everything with you none
anymore i just feel very smothered
because you're constantly in colt's face
if i need him you're in his it's
non-stop hey cole hey cole even if our
door is closed at the room hey cole hey
cole it's non-stop yeah colt's
relationship with his mom has seemingly
gotten in the way of his marriage to
vanessa
you've raised me to be just a
subservient person to you and i just
want to know why do you understand why
i'm even mad do you even stand why i i'm
this way i am 36 years old stop treating
me like i'm a kid things get even more
heated between the mother and son as
colt speaks up for himself i i shouldn't
be bothered with your life this is your
life it's not my responsibility in life
you're not moving out where are you
moving to i'm not going to do this don't
you know what i'm not gonna do why are
you doing this what are you doing cole
what am i really doing here
i just wanna talk i wanna sit down let's
talk about vince
you just run away backstage debbie
continues ranting but eventually returns
to the stage where things continue to
escalate you can get the hell out oh
well no he can because i don't care
anymore are you coming i asked you to
come here and support me you come here
and embarrass me and tell treat me like
i'm done do you go you want to totally
destroy me is that what you want you're
doing that then the tell-all takes an
emotional turn as vanessa and colt open
up about suffering a miscarriage i
didn't want to tell you at the time when
i was driving out to san diego i didn't
want to leave her i mean it happened
nothing i could really do about it
he took me to the emergency room in the
middle of the night
and um that was that
i felt very heartbroken i felt so bad
for you vanessa blames herself for the
loss of their baby the stress she put on
herself but also the pressure that comes
with living with debbie under one roof
vanessa do you want to move back in with
your husband didn't sign up for a
part-time husband in may the couple's
relationship was in a much better place
colt finally proposed to vanessa we're
engaged we're engaged
engaged beautiful ring uh you know i
love vanessa you know she's a part of my
life she's my best friend when e.t spoke
with the reality star just months before
he popped the question he got real about
his feelings vanessa for i don't know
what it is about her but we've connected
in the past years we've come in and out
of each other's lives but we just seem
to always find each other again so is
there a chance these two could reconcile
vanessa says one thing has to happen
will you move back in
if debbie is not in the house
you